an object is moving along a line the
following graph gives the object's
position relative to its starting point
over time
for each point on the graph is the
object moving forward backward or
neither so pause this video and try to
figure that out
all right so we see we have position in
meters versus time so for example this
point right over here tells us that
after one second we are four meters
ahead of our starting point
or for example this point right over
here says that after 4 seconds we are
almost it seems almost 4 meters behind
our starting point so let's look at each
of these points and think about whether
we're moving forward backward or neither
so at this point right over here
at that moment we're about two and a
half meters in front of our starting
point we're at a positive position of
two and a half meters
but as time goes on we are moving
backwards closer and closer to the
starting point so this is we are moving
backward
one way to think about it at this time
we're two and a half meters if you go
forward about
half a second we are then back at our
starting point so we have to go
backwards
and if we look at this point right over
here
it looks like we were going backwards
this entire time while our curve is
downward sloping but at this point right
over here when we are about it looks
like five meters behind our starting
point we start going forward again
but right at that moment
we are going neither forward nor
backwards it's right at that moment
where we just finished going backwards
and we're about to go forward and one
way to think about it is what would be
the slope of the tangent line at that
point and the slope of the tangent line
at that point would
be
horizontal and so this is
neither
so we can use that same technique to
think about this point
the slope is positive and we see that
all right right at that moment it looks
like we are at the starting point but if
you fast forward even a few even a a a
fraction of a second we are now in front
of our starting point so we are moving
forward we are moving forward right over
here and at this point we are at our
starting point but if think about what's
going to happen a moment later a moment
later we're going to be a little bit
behind our starting point and so here we
are moving backwards
and we're done